pour en parler nous sommes avec eric
diard député les républicains de la 12e
circonscription des bouches-du-rhône
bonsoir monsieur dira merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france vous avez
donc mené une mission d'information sur
les services publics face au phénomène
de communautarisme et de radicalisation
quel est selon vous le bilan de la
situation
le bilan est très con strass est très
contrastée j'allais dire jeukens j'ai su
à l'initiative cette mission parce que
j'avais rencontré beaucoup de policiers
beaucoup de personnes qui travaillaient
dans le pénitencier et qui me disait en
matière de radicalisation l'expression
c'était il ya des trous dans la raquette
et donc nous avons vu différents
services publics les services régaliens
police gendarmerie armée jusqu'à nous
sommes allés dans les transports les
hôpitaux les universités les
collectivités locales et nous avons même
un domaine qui est très impacté par la
radicalisation qui relève plutôt de
l'action publique le domaine du sport le
sport c'est à dire mais nous avons
constaté nous avons été assez surpris
que dans le sport il y avait une boucle
de problématique
une problématique qui n'est pas de la
radicalisation mais qui se développe une
problématique de communautarisme nous
avons un développement très fort de
communautarisme a traversé est certes un
sport notamment le football le
basketball féminin et nous avons sur un
petit peu la sonnette d'alarmé et
deuxièmement nous avons quand même
l'infiltration d'individus radicalisés
dont j'allais dire des disciplines de
combat alors pas karaté pas le judo
elles ont un moment donné le type de
personnes ont tenté de s'infiltrer mais
quand vous refusez de vous incliner à
l'adversaire des ans je m'incline que
devant halla bon vous montrez d'aider
des signes clairs de non adaptation à ce
sport et donc d'autres alors il ya des
personnes qui ont pénétré notamment la
boxe mais surtout la boxe thaï le mma et
la lutte aussi qu'ils partent également
impacté vous fait clairement la
différence entre le communautarisme
vous dites là je parle de
communautarisme dans le sport et pas de
radicalisation en tout cas pas papa à
chaque fois est-ce que la courroie et
1 ce finalement est-ce qu'on peut passer
facilement du communautarisme à la
radicalisation ou ça n'a rien à voir
les deux choses sont bel et bien à
prendre différemment à traiter ses
parents je vous dirai à trois points il
ya d'abord les atteintes à la laïcité
qui n'ont rien à voir avec la réducation
mais qui n'ont doit pas avoir cours dans
un service public
ensuite vous avez tout ce qui relève du
communautarisme et du prosélytisme
religieux
là non plus dans un service public ça ne
devrait pas avoir cours enfin vous avez
la radicalisation ou là vous basculez
dans un processus de violence alors
c'est parfois c'est un chemin où
commencer par les attentats laïcité et
vous pouvez basculer dans le
prosélytisme puis dans l'addiction
parfois ces phases sont complètement
cloisonné
ça veut dire que vous pouvez être un
musulman très rigoureux trop rigoriste
peut-être si vous saluer pas les femmes
mais vous ne basculeraient pas dans la
violence
par contre vous avez des individus qui
ne pratiquent pas si d'humains la
religion et qui basculeront dans la
radicalisation
alors deux commission denquête on le
disait un sont à l'oeuvre un lune l
assemblée sur la sphère harpon après la
préfecture de police de paris au sénat
également sur la radicalisation
islamiste matignon apprend on le savait
déjà mais nous rappelle aujourd'hui que
16 personnes ont été écartées des
services de renseignement depuis 2014
mais alors pas de pied octobre un pas
depuis l'attentât de la préfecture mais
qu'il semblerait que 100 personnes au
total
et étaient signalées comment vous qui
avez travaillé sur ces questions a
expliqué ce delta
alors écoutez première membres je suis
encore je suis secrétaire de la
commission d' enquête sur la tacc de la
préfecture police et j'ai été
auditionnée par la commission d' enquête
du sénat alors programmant sur ces 16
personnes du renseignement depuis 2014
j'aurais souhaité avoir de la part du
gouvernement et du premier ministre et
précision parce que on peut imaginer
seize personnes du renseignement je vais
vous dire c est james bond qui ont
basculé ratification ça peut être
également des traducteurs vous avez
parfois besoin pour une écoute de
traducteurs dans une langue assez
spécifique et à cette époque là on les
recruter rapidement et après au moment
de redonner l'habilitation des bons cela
on peut pas les garder et donc parfois
c'est sûr des traducteurs j'allais dire
un contrat très courts et donc c'est
pour ça que il serait intéressant de
savoir un petit peu les différents
profils de ces personnes qui ont été
écartés nos confrères du figaro publié
une enquête aujourd'hui en dénonçant les
faiblesses justement de l'arsenal des
progrès qu'on a enregistrées depuis
cette attaque
dénonçant notamment l'arsenal juridique
n'est pas adapté souvent là on décèle
des personnes radicalisé mais on n'a pas
les moyens juridiques tout simplement d
écarter est-ce que vous avez constaté
je revois le
l'audition de madame bilan si nicky la
directrice du renseignement actuel de la
préfecture police et qui a mis en place
des process elle par contre et de
l'ancien préfet monsieur delpech qui
nous disait en matière de radicalisation
on a un angle mort juridique
je vous rappelle qu'en france vous ne
pouvez pas révoquer quelqu'un pour
radicalisation ça ne peut pas créer le
délit
parce que en face vous avez la liberté
de conscience et la liberté religieuse
qui sont constitutionnels et donc à
partir de là souvent on utilise des
motifs connexes par exemple d'ordre
disciplinaire pour évoquer les personnes
alors il ya une évolution un petit peu
dans les professions j'allais dire de de
souveraineté puisque depuis peu on peu
rétro criblé c'est-à-dire vérifier en
cours de carrière si ces personnes ne se
sont pas radicaliser et créer une
commission qui permettrait de les
révoquer pour radicalisation mais là
dessus je voulais vous donner un exemple
c'est la loi sylt du 30 octobre 2017 qui
a créé cette possibilité de prêter au
criblage pour ces les policiers les
gendarmes et bien cette loi n'est
appliqué que depuis le 24 octobre 2019
parce qu'il manquait une circulaire
interministérielle du secrétariat
général de la défense et de la sécurité
j'ai insisté dans le rapport après
l'attentât je lise et ça c'est fait
juste après à temps mais deux ans pour
mettre en place un élément de la loi
c'est trop long et comment vous
expliquez vous qui êtes
voilà un homme politique un élu
qui est ce vide juridique sur ces
questions est ce que c'est un manque de
volonté politique alors parce qu'on a
entendu le discours d' emmanuel macron
appelant la société de vigilance l'hydro
islamistes on s'en souvient bien ça veut
dire qu'il ya les paroles
il n'y a pas forcément les actes parce
que si vous n'avez pas les moyens d'agir
avec la loi ça devient le savez on n'a
pas été que lanceur dollars on a fait 35
préconisations et nous avons une clause
de revoyure avec les différents
ministres l'intérieur l'éducation qui a
l'air quand même plutôt partie qui
aurait impliqué la ministre des sports
qui n'allait qui n'allait pas du tout la
ministre de la justice pour voir un peu
quels sont les préconisations qui vont
retenir mais dans le figaro
d'aujourd'hui il parle d'une proposition
de l'eau dont je suis l initiative qui
constitutionnel il faut avancer moi je
pense que l'on doit mettre dans la
constitution et que lorsque on travaille
dans un service public on se doit de
respecter les valeurs de la république
de liberté égalité fraternité de laïcité
on doit même prêté j'allais dire serment
et pourquoi on doit prêter serment parce
que si vous faites vous ne respectez pas
votre serment en france cela s'appelle
un parjure
c'est un délit et cela permettrait de
faciliter justement la révocation qui
est difficile à établir
et donc vous avez reçu quel accueil
après cette proposition va voir je les
dépose et donc il faut faciliter la
révocation pour radicalisation c'est
très difficile moi j'ai fait cette
proposition au gouvernement je vous dis
je je suis actuellement je suis un
député opposition mais je mets en place
donc des préconisations
je mets en place aussi des lots j'ai
demandé aussi qu'on puisse étendre la
rétention de sûreté aux détenus
radicaliser parce que cela permettrait
aussi vous avez des détenus radicaliser
qui vont sortir de prison qui seront
plus dangereux à la sortie qu'à l'entrée
et ces personnes on l'a vu avec les
attentats d'angleterre passe directement
à l'acte donc faudrait peut-être donner
la possibilité au lieu d'installer une
rétention de sûreté pour qu'ils créent
un tampon entre la prison et la liberté
parce que je peux vous dire que à
travers le rapport les prisons sont
vraiment un cancer en matière de
radicalisation en axant team en vous
écoutant que les solutions tente de
venir plus tôt de l'extérieur et pas du
goût
vraiment trois anciens députés de droite
et de gauche d'ailleurs c'est assez rare
de se lier sur ce genre de questions
georges fenech un patrick mennucci et
sébastien pietrasanta ont uni leurs
forces pour former justement les élus et
les fonctionnaires la détection est la
lutte contre les radicalisations
historique islamistes ce que ce sont des
bons outils des outils efficaces il faut
par as passé justement par là la
formation des élus écoutez je les ai
rencontrés j'ai même ils m'ont proposé
d'intervenir sur justement représenté le
rapport moi je pensais d où il faut
former les élus mais il faut former
aussi j'allais dire les agents de la
fonction publique pour savoir permettre
de détecter peut-être un usager de
pouvoir faire remonter l'information
alors on va peut être que négatif il ya
un secteur qui a fait sa mue je trouve
c'est l'éducation nationale c'est à dire
l'éducationnationale les attentats de
2015 ont particulièrement marqué tous
les français mais particulier le corps
enseignant et je peux vous dire qui a
des référents radicalisation dans chaque
académie et qu'il ya un problème
l'information remonte c'est quand même
quelque chose de nouveau il ya encore
beaucoup des figures et l'éducation
nationale et je peux vous dire comme que
le ministre blanc caire quand même a
pris la mesure de la gravité de la
situation c'est pas le cas de tous les
ministres on terminera sur cette note
optimiste merci eric diard député
les républicains de la 12e
circonscription des bouches-du-rhône
merci d'avoir été avec nous